alright let's talk about what's been
considered to be concentration camps gay
concentration camps in Chechnya this is
a report coming from NBC News reported
by Mary O'Hara it we actually covered it
on my show two weeks ago there was a
demonstration LGBT rights demonstration
and in that demonstration over 100 men
gay men were detained and about three
were reported having been killed though
of those 100 men that were detained
there reports that are coming out that
they are being tortured in secret
detention centers they have at least 30
different messages from since April 2nd
of people who are have either escaped or
have witnessed the torture the the type
of treatment that they're getting and
some as many as 20 have been reported as
being killed the the situation in
Chechnya with regard to gay and lesbian
members of their community is like this
they don't even acknowledge that gay
people exist in Chechnya and you know so
they say how can this happen to gay
people in Chechnya when there are no gay
people in Chechnya it's like when
President Mahmoud Ahmadinejad the
Iranian former president spoke to
Columbia University and he says that we
don't have gays in our country yeah
absolutely I mean and and to use that as
a position as to why this atrocity
couldn't be happening to me as evidence
that this atrocity is probably very
seriously happening there are men who
escaped these these concentration camps
would have been called gay concentration
camps and the men who escaped said that
in these rooms that they are being
detained in they're squeezing 15 to 30
prisoners they're held without food
they're being tortured with electric
shock and there are shocks and they're
being beaten
sometimes beaten to death and you know
Chechnya says this can't happen because
there's no gay men in Chechnya
relatively speaking I would say that
Chechnya is certainly worse off than the
rest of the Russian government when it
comes to LGBT issues but we know that
Russia is
that no standard there for that as well
because even about a week or two ago
Vladimir Putin banned an image of him
where he's depicted as a clown yeah that
made a lot of headlines yeah I mean
Russia is know is by far not a panacea
for the LGBTQ community with their
recent legislation banning the
promulgation of gay propaganda to minors
at least this is the type of language
they use so there's a problem across the
board but when you consider the the
route of the LGBT hatred in Chechnya
it's sad but they actually make Russia
look better and this is why we need to
know if the Russians had any
interference in our elections or had any
prior agreement with the Trump campaign
because if this continues to go on and
our own government doesn't say anything
that tacitly helps the Russian
government yes so this is a quote that I
actually want to read and it could give
you a better insight into what's
happening over there a spokesperson for
the leader who you see of Chechnya who
you see on your screen
Rams on Cat Cat Cat Roth of forgiving he
said the spokesperson for him said you
cannot detain and persecute people who
simply do not exist in the Republic you
know this type of language shows you
what's coming from the leadership of
Chechnya what's coming it was in the
culture of Chechnya they're considered
honor killings when they kill a gay
person in Chechnya it's such a stigma
that families are broken apart if
someone is found to be gay in their
family like this is this is a stigma
that doesn't just come politically it
comes from your family unit it really
has a very strong conservative religious
dogma that makes it not only not only
painful but dangerous to be LGBTQ and
that was the latter part of a statement
right that if someone comes out to be
gay it's an issue that is dealt with
their family yet and their relatives
yeah yeah that was that was the it is
it's a fascinating and disturbing story
to see that this is happening some
people say that calling it concentration
camps is a misnomer and that it
shouldn't be called that but whether we
call it that or not something needs to
be done before it's allowed to escalate
to that level